here
pop med contains over 30 million
citations to articles in the
biomedical literature with new material added
daily
also includes citations to a small but
useful selection of books and online documents
with a clinical medicine background pop med
includes citations to literature on a
wide range of biomedical and
health topics including environmental health
social sciences microbiology genetics
and chemical and physical sciences
the largest component of pop med is
medline the
national library
of medicine's primary bibliographic database containing citations and
abstracts from authors of  over 5000
biomedical journals published worldwide
there is a process to determine whether
or not to include a journal in medline when
making this decision the nlm considers the
recommendations of a group of advisors
known as the
literature selection technical review committee the
committee  meets three times a year to
evaluate the journals that have been  n
metlife application journals are
selected based on scope and
coverage editorial policies and processes
scientific rigor production and
administration and impact
poch med also includes citations and
abstracts of articles included in
pubmed central or if an archive
free online full-text
journals of biomedical and life sciences journals
also hosted by the
national library of medicine for
a journal to be included in pop med
central it must meet
the
national library of medicine collections quality criteria and
comply with
pgjem scientific editorial and technical criteria whether
when research is
funded by the national institutes
of health or in high age
the results should be made available
to the public therefore
individual articles published as a
result of
anaheim-funded research
are also  included in pubmed c  entral
promise central also serves as a
repository for articles reporting
on research funded by
other public agencies and
private research funders who share a
similar mission to the angels records
of these articles in pop met central
sharing
research results with  the public are
added to pop med even if the article
is not published in a journal
selected for met line or pop met
central
pop med also provides access to the books
the end line of the national center for
biotechnology information the book self
has over 7000 technical reports
systematic reviews clinical guidelines
reference works and other monographs
most pop med records
represent a journal article and
have fields that provide
specific information about the article
including journal
source information journal
article title journal
names  the authors and their  s
affiliations abstract published with the
article and the type of publication or
description of the article type such as
review or letter for articles not
in English pop med records
will also include the language in which
the article was published when it becomes
available on  pop med registry
will provide information on
research funding and
associated study data
the national library of medicine
adds medical topic descriptors or
terms more are included in the
registries of metlife selected journals
mesh terms provide quick access
to the  Article Subjects
Most of Pop Med's records
are provided electronically by
the publishers and are enhanced with
months and links to related resources from
the National Library of Medicine
as well as providing free access to Pop
Med via the
National Library of Medicine's web.  medicine offers researchers access to
pop med data
commercial providers and the public
for reuse and repurposing
pop makes it easy for me to find
information from biomedical journals from
anywhere I can access the
internet